Okay, I want to start the session. So welcome, everyone.
I'm Gadi Getz. I'm from Mass General Hospital and the Broad
Institute, and I welcome you to this session on new insights from
TCGA whole-genome sequencing. And since this is
an educational session, I will start first with a kind of longer
introduction about TCGA, and if you are new to cancer genomics
and the whole-genome sequencing that was done together with TCGA data.
So here are my disclosures.
So it's useful, when you think about cancer genomics, to think about the whole
life history of cancer. Cancer is a disease of the genome and the epigenome.
We all start from a single fertilized egg with
DNA coming from mom and dad, and potentially also with
possible germline risk alleles. As cells divide, or
even if they don't divide, they accumulate DNA damage, and there are repair
mechanisms in the cells that are used to repair the damage, but the
damage that is not repaired can stay as mutations.
Most of those mutations don't do anything. We call them passenger events.
But occasionally, there could be an event that increases the fitness of the
cells, and the clone starts to either grow faster or die
slower, and it accumulates, and that clone grows.
This is still not cancer. It occurs in every tissue in our body.
But then it continues to divide in the clone and many more passenger
events occur. And here's another driver event that increase further the
fitness of the cells, and they start to take over the population of cells.
And here's another driver. And this one is the last clonal driver,
meaning that all the cancer cells are descendant of that cell.
And this is very important because that means that the cancer cells
have all the mutations that were acquired all the way back in this lineage
from this cell all the way to the fertilized egg.
And then cancer continues to evolve with subclones driven by
drivers. And then when cancer is diagnosed, the DNA
is highly altered with between
300 and 300,000 mutations in the genome.
The genome, just to remind people, is 3 billion bases.
But only a handful of these mutations are actually the drivers that gave the
cells the fitness advantage, and potentially zero or one of these
germline risk alleles.
After treatment, cancer continues to evolve, but since TCGA and also
ICGC, which we'll mention, the PEACOCK project,
worked on primary tumors, we won't focus on this today.
Now, where are all these mutations coming from?
They are coming from mutational processes that occur
in different cells in the body. There are these aging
processes like this deamination of methylated cytosine in CpGs,
and they occur in all cells in the body.
There could be carcinogens, like cigarette smoke or UV light, that generate their
own pattern of mutations. And also, there could be some driver events that
create defects in DNA repair genes, and from that point on,
the damage that would have been repaired is not
repaired as efficiently, and you get more mutations in with their
signatures. And of course, if the tumor is treated with the
DNA-damaging agent, there could have also signatures or
processes that are caused by, for example, chemotherapy.
But again, we'll talk about primary tumors that are mostly untreated.
So in order to study all of these aspects, and particularly these driver
mutations, there are cancer genome projects started two
decades ago, including TCGA. And the main
goal is to generate a comprehensive list of genes and pathways
and regions of the genome that drive cancer.
Also find molecular subtypes and study mutational processes,
what generates mutations, and associate all of these findings with outcome of
the cancer. Of course, when I say cancer is a disease of the genome and
epigenome, is because also epigenetic changes that are copied from mother cell
to daughter cell also can be kind of cancer-causing.
So this is the TCGA project, started in 2006,
with studying three tumor types and then extended in 2009 to study
33 tumor types, 20 kind of larger tumor types and
13 more rare cancer types that are smaller cohorts.
And then it's formally ended generating data in 2016
and published a comprehensive analysis
of all the data in 2018. Now, every tumor in
TCGA, tumor normal pair, had
whole exome sequencing. Roughly 10% had originally PCR
plus
deeper whole-genome sequencing, and 20% had low-coverage whole-genome
sequencing, and then RNA-Seq for mRNA and microRNA, SNP arrays,
methylation arrays, some proteomic data with reverse phase
protein arrays, and clinical data.
Similar projects around the world,
combined under the umbrella of the International Cancer Genome Consortium, aim
to study 50 tumor types, again, with the same study design of 500 tumor
normal pairs each. So there are more recent large-scale
projects, including kind of in Genomics England, and BC Cancer, and
Hardwick Medical Center, and ICGC Argo, and Japan Cancer
Sequencing, and others that are studying kind of large-scale cancer genomics.
So what are the key tasks in cancer genomics?
Once you start, you get these tumor normal pairs.
The first thing is to identify all the changes that happen from normal cells
to cancer cells, and we call this characterization, finding all these
somatic events, including also finding the germline events, and that's per
individual.
Then we take all this data across a cohort of patients
and study, and we call that phase interpretation, where we discover
new drivers and subtypes and associate it with
outcome and mutational processes and things like that.
The power for these studies
come from
sequencing depth of the-- in the individual, sequencing depth and quality and
read length, and for the discovery part, the size of the
cohort.So this is the TCGA and all tumor types in TCGA.
Every tumor type was studied, and then at some point,
a paper came out, we call it the marker paper, and studied some number of
cases. And then later on, more cases were
acquired, and that's the column of the cases of
characterized, and overall, 11,000 cancers.
So in 2018,
all of the data were harmonized and processed together in this
effort called the Pan-Can Atlas, and multiple papers were published in three
categories. And all the mutations were processed by multiple
centers and called this MC3 for
multi-center mutation calling in multiple cancers.
Then joining forces with ICGC, created this project called
the PEACoG, Pan-Cancer Analysis of Whole Genomes, focusing on
2,600 tumor normal pairs for whole genomes, because the
Pan-Can Atlas focused mostly on whole exome data.
And that also was analyzed in a large cohort of
researchers around the world, publishing in 2020, a bunch of
papers, a collection of papers, and here are some examples of papers
that were published. And the main key findings of
the PEACoG was that the cancer has on average four to five drivers.
The majority of drivers are in coding regions.
Third promoter mutation is an outlier.
5% of cancers have no clear driver.
Cancer clones initiate decades before diagnosis.
Many cancers harbor complex genomic events like chromothripsis or
chromoplexy or retrotransposition.
There are different mutational processes for single-base substitutions or
double-base substitutions and indels.
Some of them, the etiology is known, some is unknown.
8% of cancer have predisposition germline alleles, and
tumor types and cell of origin could be predicted by the pattern of mutations.
What are the limitations of PEACoG? There are four main limitations.
One is the lower depth of sequencing with only 30 to 50X
coverage. There are missing mutations because the PCR amplification
of the whole genomes not
amplifies well GC-rich regions, so
you lose mutations. And there's, sorry, lack of power
because the number of tumors per tumor type was relatively
small, and some of the drivers are tumor type specific, particularly the
regulatory ones. And not all of the PEACoG had
other data types, as opposed to TCGA, where all these
other data types like RNA and microRNA and proteomics, et cetera.
So since then, TCGA
and the NCI sequenced deeply these whole genome
sequencing of nearly all of the TCGA cases, more than
8,500 tumor normal pairs.
Deep sequencing of 80X with newer technologies of
sequencing. They are PCR-free rather than PCR
plus, and there's all this rich and curated dataset like
whole exome and RNA-Seq and microRNA-Seq, et cetera.
And as you can see in this plot, the blue is the
8,500 cases compared to the yellow, which were done in the PEACoG.
How do you get to this data? You could go to the GDC, the Genomics Data
Commons, and put your dbGaP credentials and select the right samples
that you want and filter them to have the high coverage, and then you could
download those whole genome sequencing data.
Now, this session will have three speakers.
Jason Pitt will start with representation learning over
cancer genomes, scaling petabytes to predictions.
Then Marcin Imielinski will talk about dimensional structural chromosome
instability in human cancers. And we'll finish with my talk on systematic analysis
of more than 8,000 TCGA whole genomes, and the goal is to have
20 minutes talk and seven minutes Q&A.
So thank you, and Jason, it's all yours.
Okay, great. Thanks for the introduction, Gad, and really, thanks to the
ACR, the organizers, the session chair for inviting me to be here.
I'm really excited to share my
thoughts and work with all of you here.
So I want to quickly say, just as Gad did, as this is an educational session, the
first part of this, I'll
be making sure, again, to give an introduction to how we've analyzed mutational
patterns over the past 15 years or so.
So if you're quite familiar with this process, I assure you as in, if you
know mutational signatures, I assure you towards the end, there'll be some new
ideas and insights I think will interest you, but please bear with me while we all
get up to speed.
Before we start, nothing to disclose.
But
really, let's ground the conversation in genome instability.
So genome instability acts as both an enabler and a vulnerability in
cancer. So what do I mean by genome instability?
Really, it's the propensity of cells to continuously accumulate more and more
mutations. And when this occurs, this can be a benefit to
cancer development and progression in the sense that it provides
enough genomic diversity for cancer cells to use
in terms of adaptations, selection, and also expansion.
Just giving a little example of how that can happen in terms of hypoxia on the
left-hand side. But also important to remember that DNA damage
itself or genome instability, I should say, can be a vulnerability with
cancer as well, and where certain drugs, such as platinum, will
actually increase DNA damage further,
hoping to overwhelm cancer cells with too much DNA damage that they can't just
possibly survive, or other drugs, such as PARP inhibitors that
are meant to prevent DNA repair, but the same concept to try to overwhelm the
cells.
So looking for genome instability and recognizing these various patterns is quite
important. And this is where the newly released TCGA data
really does become important. So I won't highlight all of these points.
Gad, I think covered that. I think I have 90X here. I would actually trust Gad.
Maybe it is 80X and I'm a little off.
But the whole point is that this is a lot of data.
All of the BAM files that are on GDC, it's about five petabytes of data.
It's a lot of data to sift through, but this is really, really cool dataset
to explore things like genome instability, but other things as
well.And why look at genomes in
terms of genome instability? Really, if you think about panel
sequencing, it only covers about 0.1% of the genome, while
theoretically, whole-genome sequencing should cover 100%.
And then also when you're at 80 to 90x sequencing, you have
hundreds of base pairs of bases that you're sequencing.
So lots and lots of information. Information is going to be a very
consistent theme of what I'm talking about today.
And really, there are specific benefits to using whole-genome sequencing in
terms of exclusive phenomena that I think Gad highlighted that you can detect from
that type of data. So non-coding drivers, retrotranspositions,
complex SVs. But something that I think is not
appreciated as much is that you can also get
more robust metrics from certain outputs.
So for example, if you look at ploidy or if you look at
mutational signature activities, the stability of mutational profiles, subclonal
architecture, you can get these things from exomes as well, but the data
from whole-genome tends to be a bit more robust.
And speaking of mutational profiles, I just want to highlight the taxonomy of
somatic mutations. I'm sure many of you have seen this before, but if you look at
the right-hand side, these are just COSMIC-based definitions of single-base
substitution profiles, indel, structural variant, copy number.
So the numbers there represent the number of features, and so each mutation of
that particular type will go into one of those slots on that histogram.
So this is really a way of doing featurization of
whole-genome data. So you strip away the actual coordinates of where a
mutation occurs, and you're saying, "Well, what's the local mutation context and
where this is actually happening?" And based on that, you end up categorizing them
into one of those channels, and that's what makes up your
profile itself. And these are really biologically informed a priori designs
of how these profiles were constructed.
And really the workhorse related to analyzing
these profiles is something called non-negative matrix factorization.
I'm sure, again, if you're familiar with signatures, you've heard of this.
But really,
non-negative matrix factorization, or NMF, was a method that was
popularized in the late '90s in terms of just a general method, not specific
within genomics. But it's really learning parts-based
representation of
particular profiles. And really it has
this constraint where it is non-negative, meaning that it's linear and the
parts have to be additive. And
pretty much any application of NMF, what you're really saying is you have visible
variables, and then you actually try to approximate them by multiplying
hidden variables by weight. So you're trying to estimate these.
So in the context of mutational signatures, which was pioneered by Alexandrov and
colleagues and a bunch of folks at Sanger, Serena Nik-Sin and all as well,
that's where you end up having your visible profiles.
You're trying to estimate the signatures that are present in that data.
And then also you get your W matrix, which is the activities of those signatures
within those particular patients.
And when we apply this to large collections of data, you can
actually define signatures you have, just the toy example on the left-hand
side there. And again, once you define
these signatures robustly across...
These days, we're talking thousands if not tens of thousands of
genomes that are required to really be at the scale that
some of the big players are operating.
Once you have that, you start to look for etiologies.
Here are two classic ones that have been around for quite a while.
So you have SBS2, which is related to apobec base mutagenesis.
Just giving you another example with ID3, where that's related to tobacco smoking.
But the whole point is once you end up having these mutational signatures,
you can assign them etiologies. Not all of them will have etiologies.
We're still trying to
understand what many of these do. But then they're often released by these large
consortiums or larger groups who pioneer this work as catalogs.
So here I'm just highlighting COSMIC and Signal.
And for these, you can use these catalogs for reference
signature assignment. So you assign it to your own data.
Maybe it can be a comparison to signature extraction that you're doing over your
own data as well, but also just a comprehensive
resource for understanding mutagenesis patterns in general across many different
mutational classes.
So
really this process has evolved quite a bit in terms of the timeline of mutational
signatures. We went from 21 breast cancer genomes where
five single-base substitution signatures were discovered, to now we're looking at
hundreds of different signatures across many, many different mutational classes.
And along with this, again, these tools have been developed, such as
SigProfiler by the Alexandrov lab, signature tools led by the Nik-Sin and all
lab. I believe Gad's group has Signature Analyzer.
Various tools that allow different groups to then
take these reference signatures and essentially look at the activities of these
various signatures in their samples or even try to extract their own.
And the point being here is that mutational signature analysis, if you're working
with exomes or genomes, is pretty much standard these days.
Especially if you're looking at any new cohort, you're going to be asked what
signatures are present, are there new signatures there, et cetera.
And this timeline is continuing. Just a couple of months ago, a paper by
Everall and colleagues came out in "Nature Genetics" where they identified
136 signatures where 26 of them are new, and they did a
comprehensive analysis across the five main classes of
mutational types that have been analyzed.
So this was done over Genomics England data.
So not TCGA, but Genomics England.
They had some cool findings from there, such as the scars of exogenous
mutational processes
looking like they occur earlier, being more clonal events compared to
endogenous ones. But another interesting aspect,
and this type of analysis has been done before, but since it's Genomics England,
they have their whole genome data that's connected to more clinical records.
So they're able to look at signatures, associate them with overall survival, and
then also look at therapeutic response as well, and see if they're associated with
those signatures.So related to that,
I just thought it'd be worth talking briefly a bit about the clinical relevance of
mutational signatures.
Here are just three examples, but I think these are the big ones where this comes
up, and this is highlighting all the three different types where you can have
signatures aid detection of a particular phenotype, and if you detect that
phenotype, those patients are eligible for a certain treatment
option in which it's been shown that those individuals that have that
phenotype are likely to respond to that therapy.
So here's one, homologous
recombination deficiency, which will be coming up again later.
Multiple signatures associated with it, and then you have tools like HRDetect,
Sigma, that try to take those signatures explicitly and try to refine them in a
way that you can actually predict cases that you think are HRD and will respond to
therapeutics. And the same is the case for mismatch repair
deficiency and high tumor mutational burden, where you can actually use
signatures to try to better inform predictive tools to say, "Do you think this
patient would respond to a therapy or not?"
So given that background, I think here's just the slight pivot that
I think is very important to recognize, is
that NMF and mutational signatures themselves are absolutely
fantastic. They've given such insights
to so many things that we were unaware of before those methods were
applied. But it's important to recognize that identifying the cause of
something is different from predicting an outcome.
So in the sense where NMF itself really excels of
looking at understanding mutational processes and looking at a patient saying,
"What is the likely source of these mutations that we're seeing?" It's not
exactly optimized to do clinical predictions.
It doesn't mean it can't be used for this, but that's not necessarily its purpose.
Its purpose was to do the math that I've showed in the previous slide, and not
necessarily predictions based on the activities of that matrix
outputs. So there are other approaches that you could utilize that
will ask, "Will a patient respond to therapy?" And again, you, of course, can
utilize this, but I think it's worth thinking... Sorry.
You can utilize NMF and signatures to do clinical prediction. It has been working.
But the question is, are there other ways to do it as well?
And this is primarily because we're constantly within the AI ML
field, I think, and especially in biology, trying to balance
interpretability and information loss.
So in the context of whole genome sequencing, on the left-hand side, you have
billions of reads, massive volume, high noise, tons of
information there, but very hard to manage or even build a model around, right?
A substantial compute required if you're going to try to do something like that.
But we tend to then distill them down to variant calls so we can understand which
mutations are occurring in patients, quite important.
But from there, you can collapse them into the mutational profiles that we talked
about, and from there, mutational profiles, you can get signatures.
Or signature activities, I should say.
And so when you're moving left to right, you are getting an increase in
human interpretability of the data. Yeah?
And very important for us to understand the biological underpinnings of some of the
things that we're seeing. But it's important to recognize, as you do that same left
to right, you're also losing information content. Yeah?
And so it's really when you're going through this process, I look
at each of these steps as a variant of lossy compression of the
data, where you're slowly getting things that are distilled a bit more and more.
We can interpret them, but you may have lost something that you can never recover
from the very downstream data. And so I think a key question
then is, instead of just... If I highlight that, yeah.
Instead of looking at mutational signature activities, well, what if we step
back? And what if we actually model the mutational profiles themselves?
And you could even ask the same question, why not keep going back?
And I think that will start to happen more and more actually.
But the step that we took is why not actually model mutational profiles
and then see
if that can do better predictive tasks.
And that's really
where we come to this idea of neural representation or
representation learning for predictive tasks.
So on the left-hand side, I have traditional NMF.
As I said, it's linear, it's additive, it's independent in terms
of data views. So now I know I'll pivot a little bit.
I've been referring to it as mutational classes, but within my group,
we always talk about these as views of the data.
It's a different type of mutation that just represents genome instability.
And oftentimes these views or classes,
usually within NMF, they are very independent.
You don't extract signatures typically of indels and SBS
together. So you don't look for interactions between those two data types.
And that makes sense biologically and
interpretation-wise, because we think mutational
processes should be operating on a certain type of mutation.
But I think especially with HRD, I always say it's an interesting case
where you have
signatures that are associated with the HRD phenotype that are across all four of
the major classes, and even five, if you count double-base
substitutions. So really, then if you're looking at neural
representations, you have a situation where these types of approaches are
non-linear. They can capture complex interactions.
They can look for relationships across mutational profiles.
So again, the different mutational classes or views.
And then also they can be supervised.
If you really are trying to do a predictive task, generalized learning is great,
but almost everything you're doing some form of supervised learning over it at some
point.
So here I'm just
highlighting the way that my lab has been looking at this problem, and
that's doing multi-view learning over mutational profiles itself.
And on the left-hand side was just our initial investigations of, is this method
viable or is this thought process viable?
So here we're showing just PEACOG data on the left-hand side, and what is
on the top left plot there is we're showing the
correlation between all cross view pairs.
So all SBS features correlate with all indel features, all SBS
features correlate with all SV features, et cetera, et cetera.
And what we can see when you do that, you have pervasive relationships
that are occurring. Some of these are weak correlations, but when you're talking
about neural networks, 20% of things being correlated, that's information, and that
information very much could be useful.
And it's in general just saying these views are not independent of one another.
And I should say, when you adjust this by purity, ploidy, does that make a
difference? You still see almost the exact same pattern here.
Yeah?And now when you look at the bottom, we ended up
doing nonlinear clustering of this data.
And so while I can't necessarily look at this and say, "Well, you have
nonlinear patterns that are emerging," we can at least say that there are clearly
complex relationships that are occurring across these views based on this
clustering and what we're seeing here.
So again, giving more evidence that there may be some interactions.
So really we thought about doing this in terms of a shared representation approach
and doing this type of learning.
And here's just an example of us doing this.
So this is HR Difuse, which is multi-view learning for pan-cancer HRD prediction.
We did this across the majority, or all of PECAUG, but
then we specifically went into TCGA using all of the old TCGA data
that Gad mentioned, and explicitly asked which of these cases have evidence for
being HRD, in the case of being BRCA1 or BRCA2 inactivated, and
specifically grabbed all of those samples.
Because for learning tasks like this, the problem is often positive data.
There's lots of negative data out there, and usually
from what we've seen, there's enough negative data.
The problem is having enough positive data.
So we did that, and when we talk about the HR Difuse model itself, here
we have the four different views. Each of these have their own encoder,
so each of these are encoded. Then they're actually fused by self-attention
within this latent space that you have here.
But we also have another training objective here where we use contrastive learning
to actually shape these encodings in a way that once they're in the latent
space, they're able to effectively pull like samples together and push
non-like samples apart from one another, which we've actually found
is quite effective in terms of this
method. So not implying contrastive learning at the
classification head, but doing it in terms of helping shape encodings.
And once it gets to classification, classification will use that latent space to
try to predict if a sample is HRD or HRP.
And again, in this case, HRD are BRCA1, BRCA2 inactivation.
And here I'm just showing the benchmarking just straight into it.
So we had to compare this to
two premier tools that do HRD prediction.
One is Cord, which is a random forest-based classifier.
The other is HRDetect, which uses lasso regression and actually featurizes
based on mutational signatures themselves.
And when you look at both the AUROC and the AUPRC, you see that HR
Difuse does perform better than both these models by a fair margin.
You compare to pure NMF, that approach actually struggles quite a bit,
making the point that I was saying earlier of not all tools are good at
everything. But also, and I think this is going to become more
and more critical as people keep throwing AI models out there,
is that we retrain Cord and HRDetect on our same exact data.
And what we saw when we did that is they still cannot perform as well as HR Difuse.
But this is going to start to be critical because you have this question of are
performance gains you're getting, is it due to your data set being different, or is
it due to your method being better?
So I would highly encourage folks to especially test this early with your
model to see how it's doing, if all other comparable
approaches are doing with your own data.
And when we look at inactivation type, we see some interesting things as well.
Essentially, where you start to see performance differences across the three tools
are when you look at more somatic inactivation.
So these are things that don't involve germline
predisposition allele at all. It's purely somatic
mutations, could be homozygous deletion, could be somatic mutation that is
expected to be pathogenic, non-pathogenic plus LOH, but then
also methylation. And again, some interesting patterns
emerging. When you look at BRCA-associated cancers, all three tools do
relatively okay here. This might have something to do with the germline
predisposition pattern that you're seeing here as well.
But when you look at non-BRCA associated cancers, so breast, ovary,
pancreas, prostate, you end up seeing a big performance difference here.
And again, when we actually retrain, there are interesting patterns
that we see as well, where Cord actually does a bit better when it retrains on our
data, indicating that it could learn from that, but still not as well as HR Difuse.
But when we train HRDetect itself, there really is no improvement that we
saw there, indicating that featurization might actually just be really good for
BRCA-associated cancers, and not maybe more complex non-BRCA associated
cancers.
And we had to come and try to ask why, and I'll try to get through this part real
quick. We think it has quite a bit to do with micromality deletions, and the fact
that not all cases have this canonical scar of HRD, these high
micromality deletion proportions, and that's being indicated there.
But we think LOO affects about 23% of cases.
We took extreme care our second time about doing this to make sure that we are
actually calling cases that HRD in a very rigorous way, only
pathogenic, non-pathogenic mutations, allele-based homozygous
deletion calls, making sure everything's standard to the community, just to make
sure that there aren't other explanations of why these might have low micromality
deletions. But the interesting thing too is that these
LOO cases are in risk for other BRCA-ness patterns as well.
So giving this intermediate phenotype between high micromality
deletion cases and HRPs.
And here's just showing that it's key because HRDetect and Cord
micromality deletions are the primary feature that they use within their models to
predict HRD. And you can see here all the tools typically do well with high, but
then only HR Difuse is able to really pick up some of the lows.
But as you can see, still could be improvement here based on any
tool. But then I think this is a critical part, which I'll just try to spend a
minute and a half on, or two minutes quickly, is why is this practically important?
And here we really leverage the new TCGA data in order to find every
case that it has that has platinum response data, particularly cisplatin and
carboplatin. And so we intentionally collected a group of
cancers that are quite difficult, and that would be non-BRCA
associated cancers. Difficult in the sense of platinum prediction
we assumed would not be easy there, or it would at least be harder than
your classical ovarian cases with HRD.
And what you can see on the bottom left is this effectively micromality deletions
alone in that cohort do not differentiate responders and
non-responders. And because of that, you see tools like Cord and HRDetect
not doing well in that group. And to give them credit, I don't think they were ever
designed for this. I don't think they looked for this or tested for this, but I
think it's still important to point out.But HRDFuse here can
actually... This isn't a good F1 where it's at now, but we thought, "Okay, this is
showing promise. Can we leverage the framework further?" And this is where neural
representation learning really benefits, and that is the concept of transfer
learning. And this is unique to HRDFuse.
CORG and HRDTech, based on their models, can't do it.
So the easiest explanation I could find is think of it like this.
You are
pre-training a model to detect cats.
You've done that, and now that you've trained a model to detect cats, now you want
to
be able to detect a subset of cats, lions.
So what you can do is you can actually freeze your feature extractor and then
build a new classifier that says, "I want to detect lions." So the
idea is you can learn from cat representations in order to better predict
lions instead of training a whole new classifier on lions themselves.
So for us, BRCA1 and BRCA2 loss is our cat, and platinum
response is our lion.
And here are the results when we do that, and you can see HRDFuse fine-tuned on the
left-hand side.
To be honest, we're a bit shocked by how well we're able to do here.
So this is approaching 0.75 in terms of F1.
You can see that eclipses the
performance of all our predictive tools, including HRDFuse baseline, and
also when we retrain directly on platinum response.
So that's the idea of we train a model just looking for lines.
It does not do as well as the fine-tune model, indicating learning the BRCA1,
BRCA2 representations actually benefited the model.
And on the right-hand side, I'm just showing how we validate that in another small
cohort of non-BRCA associated cancers, which we found was very hard to come by, but
we found one to at least validate on. So the last slide.
So I think hopefully I convinced you that neural representation learning has a lot
of promise, especially when you're trying to predict clinical phenotypes using
genome instability patterns. And from what I showed, you can see lots of folks are
trying to do that task.
TCGA, it's so cool that they have this whole genome data now, especially for us,
because I truly think it's unlocked as a modality, where now we can look at
multimodal models that involve whole genome sequencing.
And I don't know all the data types that things like Genomics England and Hartwick
has, but this is, I think, going to be very unique to TCGA and what it's actually
unlocking in terms of multimodal modeling.
And I think doing these types of representation learning could really start
complementing mutational signatures, where you're using parallel approaches, one
that's really trying to look for etiologies and one that's trying to do prediction.
So with that, I'd just like to end. Thank my lab, thank
collaborators, thank Anand and Ashalok for contributing to this quite greatly, and
Andy and Aakanksha for doing fantastic work on this.
And I'd be happy to take questions. Thank you.
Before the question, I'm
going to look to see if there are questions from the-
Oh, sure.
From the audience.
Yes.
Oh, sorry.
Mic.
Richard.
Hi, Jason. Great talk. And so I have a couple of questions.
The first question is that your
HRDFuse's performance with your
algorithm are a little bit reduced in
non-breast cancer cases. So what is the reason?
This is the first question. Second question is that you tested
the performance using the BRCA mutation as a
ground truth.
Mm-hmm.
But then detecting mutation
much quicker way.
Why? So what is the significance of
developing the new algorithm to detect
other HRD or something like that?
Yeah. Thank you, Professor Gawande. Very good question.
So,
for us, yes, we did use non-BRCA associated.
To be honest, we pressed through this for a revision.
This fine-tuning method is actually showing evidence within ovarian
cancers as well, actually. So we think it's not necessarily specific to
non-BRCA associated, even the fine-tuning for platinum response part.
So, very quite interesting there.
But the second part, I think
using BRCA1 and BRCA2 as labels is always a problem.
I think we're always going to have this problem with HRD, of that
you're going to have non-perfectly labeled data, where you're going to
have positive cases within whatever you are calling negatives because you
just don't know that they're positive yet. It's going to be quite difficult.
But I'm hoping that when you start having platinum response combined with
BRCA1 and BRCA2 loss, HRR, other HRR genes, all this,
and especially PARP inhibitor response, if we
can ever find whole genome there, we can start really disentangling what's what in
terms of the patterns that we're seeing.
Specifically, your
algorithm can discriminate pathogenic and
non-pathogenic BRCA mutations?
Very good question. So we've looked, and it
can, but we haven't formalized as much where is it something
where you have a VUS, but it's predicted to be closer to being
pathogenic? Are we higher for those predictions than others?
We haven't fully looked at that yet, though. But that would be quite interesting.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you for the talk. I have a quick question regarding the HRD and the
problem of multi-channel representation.
Mm-hmm.
So I was interesting to see that your deletions with microhomology are not
present in all the tumors with BRCA1 or BRCA or
other homologous recombination repair genes.
But what do you think is the reason for that?
It wouldn't be the case that actually there are multiple alternative
repair pathways that are active in those tumors, and not
all the tumors have the same alternative repair pathways that are
like TMJ, leaving these non-homolog, microhomology deletions
that are active. So did you look beyond that?
What are the features that inform your
HRDFuse and whether by introducing additional features
from alternative repair pathways-
Yeah
... you can actually improve the predictions?
Yeah.That's actually a very great question.
So I don't have those results to show here. We're doing it.
So we actually just did another round of retraining for the revision for this.
So I don't want to say things that were with the old model that might not be true
now, but you're exactly right. So we contrasted those
cases, the high and the lows, and actually did integrated gradients and integrated
Hessians on there to try to ask what features are actually discriminating these two
groups. So I don't have the answer straight away, but
I think that is actually very important to do.
But with the microhomology-mediated deletion, some work
that Chuck Venkitaraman and I had in a cell paper about a year and a half
ago is quite interesting that when we showed that within cell lines,
that you can actually get the emergence of SBS3 when you're actually knocking out
BRCA2 without the emergence of microhomology deletions.
Why that was occurring and so consistently, I don't know.
But I'm really wondering, I think it's going to be worth figuring out under what
circumstances can you actually break these links between these different views and
what you're actually seeing and what might compensate for them. Yeah.
Thank you.
We have maybe time for one more question or whatever.
Maybe two more questions.
Up to you. Up to you.
But there's only two people standing here.
Yeah.
Cutoff for HRDetect is 0.6
in ovarian tumors, but pancreatic cancer is associated with
much lower tumor purity.
Mm-hmm.
So,
is the cutoff should be lower with pancreatic cancer or
tumor with lower purity?
Hmm.
So that, it's a fair point. It's something that we didn't look at as tumor specific
cutoffs. Of course, when you look at the AUPRCs and the AUROCs, it is
measuring across all probability cutoffs that you could use and trying to estimate
overall model performance. But it is something that we can't preclude, that within
one cancer type at a certain cutoff, that
HRDetect might be better than HRDfuse, vice versa, or even cord for
that matter. But it is worth looking at very specific cutoffs within cancer types
because of course that's what GIS and the myriad score actually did is, there's
very specific cutoffs for each cancer type. Yeah.
Hi, excellent talk, very inspiring.
I really like this multi-view learning framework, and my question may be a
little bit staying ahead of time, but I want to hear your comments say,
different tumors might have different biologies, like maybe some
have emphasized more on the mutation side, which is the focus of this talk.
Hmm.
But what are you thinking on maybe expression may be driving in-
Hmm
... some of the tumors? I just want to hear your-
I think that actually could be very important too, especially refining predictions,
because obviously just having these scars doesn't necessarily mean you respond to a
therapy. Could be the immune microenvironment, could be expression of certain
genes. So I think there's going to be interplay there.
So I think multimodal models are going to be really important, and I also
think feature engineering is going to start to be very important too, where who's
to say these profiles are actually going to be the ones that accurately predict
every clinical phenotype? It might start changing.
We have to figure out which ones actually carry the most information for the most
phenotypes, I think.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Great.
There's another question here that was about how to access the data, and
the answer to that question from online is that you need to get to
TCGA data, get dbGaP approval,
and then
sign all the agreements there, and then you could download the data.
And Marcin Imielinski, it's all yours.
Great. Thanks, Gaddy. Thank you to the
organizers, and great to see such a big crowd for
TCGA, and hats off to Gaddy and a lot of the
visionaries who created the project.
I have many fond memories of training at the Broad during the
sort of glory days, and they're still happening.
The glory days are now.
We're going to be talking about analyses of thousands of cancer whole genomes, and
I think
while we are excited about that, I think we also have to think about
why aren't we analyzing hundreds of thousands or millions of cancer whole genomes?
And I think a lot of the questions that we're asking, the really deep,
fundamental questions, will benefit from that kind of scale.
And I think we look for inspiration, for example, in the germline community,
cardiovascular disease, or all kinds of common diseases where they've gotten to
numbers like the millions, or even in targeted sequencing, very elegant
studies revealing surprising results from MSK, for example.
I think I saw Mike Berger in the audience,
from looking at tens of thousands of samples.
So I think,
let's get down to the topic at hand.
So one of the reasons we're interested in analyzing cancer
whole genomes is to study something called chromosomal instability.
What is chromosomal instability?
Well, there's actually,
Nature commissioned this review on that topic, and I sort of crashed the
party, so I've gotten some of the insights from the leaders
in the field about it. But here's a little bit how I think about it, and
particularly what's relevant for cancer genomics.
So when we think about cancer genomes evolving,
we think of many defective cellular pathways that
are sort of regulating the homostasis of the genome from
sort of nucleotide base excision, mismatch repair,
double-stranded break repair, and replication, and then
mitosis and nuclear integrity and telomere end protection.
And these are sort of processes that have much different biology and
operate on very different
scales. And I don't really know what the left-hand side is, but I think the
right-hand side is more of what we think about in terms of SIN.
And there's some really exciting concurrent sessions and later in the
day by Sam Vakharia and others, thinking about the therapeutic
opportunities that arise, particularly from the right-hand
side of this diagram. Now, when we
triangulate this with the cancer genome, we can think about
somatic events that happen on different scales.
Point mutations that alter single or a few nucleotides,
rearrangements that join distant regions or segments of the genome,
and what we call chromosomal alterations that
affect megabases of DNA.And we have names for
signatures, and Jason very elegantly reviewed some of the
approaches for deconvolution these straight from data
from SBS and indel signatures, rearrangement signatures, and more
recently, copy number signatures.
And the vision here is really as we move to whole-genome molecular oncology,
that these findings can be actionable, meaning that we can
diagnose a sort of pathology, a defective
cellular pathway, and triangulate that with a targetable
synthetic lethality. And that's one way that whole
genomes, and maybe only whole genomes, will be able to inform this kind of
approach to
treatment. So when we think about these different
kind of scales of variation, there's different features that we
think about. And for SNVs, a lot of those features have been really worked out in
terms of what we care about when diagnosing a particular SNV or indel
mutational process, meaning we look at the immediate nucleotide context.
For rearrangements, these processes are generally
represented in terms of
the orientation of each junction, whether it's an inversion or a
translocation or a clustered rearrangement or not, and the length, the
span that they take.
And thinking about copy number processes,
the sort of methods have, right now, I think still a little bit nascent, and I
think this is where we have a lot of room to improve.
And when I kind of subdivided these entities,
they do exist in sort of a continuum and when we think
about mutational processes, we may have to think about many of these scales.
Now,
for better or for worse, I've spent the last decade sort of with unhealthy
obsession about the
way that copy number and rearrangements really are two coherent
sort of shadows of a single cancer genome
structure. And this is a very sort of practical
intuition, which is that there's a stoichiometry around copy
number alterations in the genome where we have segments that
might have two copies, might have five copies, and they're connected to other
segments, either in the reference through this kind of gray
edge, or through distant connections in the genome
made through rearrangement. And there's a sort of mass balance principle
around this, sort of like if you think about basic chemistry.
And the way that this is framed is that every copy of
every segment has a left and a right neighbor, or it's at a chromosome
end. And we can leverage this actually not just a kind of neat little fact, we
can leverage this to build better analytics.
And part of the output of that analytics is that we not only infer the copy
number on the segments of the genome, but also the rearrangements, the junctions
that connect them. And I think this is a very powerful starting point for thinking
about particularly structural chromosomal instability.
And so we've developed a method based around this mass balance principle
called JAVEL, and it's undergone several iterations.
Here's the poor PhD students who, well, they
put a lot of their time into this approach, and I
think it's really the state-of-the-art approach
that takes into account rearrangements and
copy number as input and outputs what I think is a state-of-the-art
copy number profiles. And here's some benchmarking we did both against an
older version of JAVEL and then the sort of rest of the pack of key
methods in the field, showing markedly sort of step change in
precision and recall for breakpoint detection and copy number
estimation on alleles and total copy number.
Now, this is obviously a good starting point, but where I
think our approach really shines is in providing this feature space that we
can start to think about structural chromosomal instability.
And part of this is sort of this gallery that I'm showing here of the kind of
events that we can diagnose by
looking at patterns in these genome graphs.
So the output of JAVEL is a genome graph, and we analyze it using a
sort of toolkit suite called gGenome, or for
graph genomes. So these are the patterns of both
simple and complex rearrangements.
And you could see that in addition to sort of deletions,
duplications, and these kind of simple events, many
other patterns can emerge and we can sort of pick them off the graph as
sort of motifs. So, for example, chromoplexy are these multi-way balanced
rearrangements that were originally identified in prostate cancer.
These templated insertion chains came from the, actually PCOG
analysis that we did with Peter Campbell and Elong Li.
And chromothripsis is this dramatic chromosome
shattering that happens when a chromosome is trapped in a micronucleus and then
within the next cell cycle or two gets reassembled.
Extrachromosomal DNA, there's a lot of interest in this field,
are these circles that can amplify and become very unstable,
and often, usually carry some
critical classic kind of oncogene.
And these other patterns like breakage-fusion-bridge cycles that I'll discuss in a
little bit.
So how did we discover these different patterns?
Here's one called rhigma, which is a chasm of nested deletions that we
analyzed in a previous-- This came out of a previous sort of study of
a few thousand, a couple of thousand cancer genomes,
where we found this clustered rearrangement pattern that wasn't chromothripsis.
It was a cluster of nested deletions with this kind of
stepwise drop in copy number. We called it rhigma, which means chasm in
Greek. These rhigma, we could tell that they're a distinct
biological entity. One thing was that these rhigma
occurred predominantly in late replicating regions of the genome.
They were also present in very large genes and
overlapped with previously annotated fragile
sites from cell line experiments.
So here's an example of what we think is a structural mutational
process that has a very distinct footprint on these graphs
that we're deriving.Another one we were just hearing a
beautiful
discussion about homologous recombination deficiency.
Here was a new structural scar of BRCA1 deficiency
that we recently uncovered, and it has a very simple sort of pattern
where you have these two duplications that are here separated by 10 or
more megabases, but often on different chromosomes.
And they're each linked to each other
with a rearrangement
junction. And what's interesting is that these can adopt very diverse
phases from copy and paste to these complex
quasi-balanced translocations, and they're highly enriched, almost
pathognomonic for BRCA1 deficiency.
Almost never seen in homologous recombination, proficient
tumors beyond one or a couple events.
So this is an example of where a particular biallelic
DNA repair deficiency correlates with
the presence of these specific graph patterns.
Now, there's been a tremendous excitement in the field about these
extrachromosomal DNA, and more broadly about
focal genomic amplifications. In fact, the chair of our
conference, Paul Michiel, has been a real champion of this field, and it's really
exciting because these focal amplifications
are extremely dynamic. They have unique biology,
and are potentially a mechanism of drug resistance and potentially
also a targetable
therapeutic opportunity. But many alterations in
cancer genomes, focal amplifications,
are chromosomally integrated.
And the classic kind of cytogenetic name for these is
homogenous staining regions. This is what they look like sort of under the
microscope to cytogeneticists decades ago.
Unlike ecDNA, they're thought to segregate symmetrically and they're stable.
And we can sort of detect very distinct footprints of these
in our genome graphs, as I
showed you that dictionary above.
So applying our approaches to thousands of
TCGA
genomes, we developed a landscape of how
frequent each of these patterns
are. And we have several patterns that qualify as
HSR in our dictionary.
And what we see is really striking, which is that
really, a lot of amplifications in cancer genomes fall
into this homogenously staining region pattern, with the exception
of glioblastoma,
where
these tumors indeed are dominated by ecDNA
amplifications of EGFR and PDGFRA and these kind of
classic oncogenes. And that's a little bit distinct, different from the
narrative in the field,
where ecDNA or B have been sort of found in many,
many places. And I think it's worth taking another look
at the dynamics of ecDNA formation.
So the key tool that you use to analyze
ecDNA is called Amplicon Architect.
So we did a head-to-head study of sort of
how frequently we detect ecDNA versus Amplicon Architect.
And you could see that
for everything but GBM, we tend to detect it much
less frequently. Now, is this just a technical kind of issue
related to
different tools making different calls?
Well, one of the kind of key
classes of amplifications that we uncovered several years
ago
didn't really fit into the description of double minute in
this case or an ecDNA or a breakage fusion bridge cycle, which is
a classic form of
a chromosomally integrated amplification. We called it Typhonis.
Typhonis had this very dramatic pattern
of
not just sort of a broad footprint of extremely
high-level amplifications, but many of these fold-back inversion
amplifications and also rearrangements that are themselves
amplified many times and occupy many
copy states. And we thought this was actually a very unique pattern.
That's why we called it Typhonis from the sort of way it looked on our
visualizations here resembling a typhoon.
And the one that we reported there showed that these Typhonis are, in fact,
massively amplified homogenously staining regions, and
this is the metaphase FISH from the same cell here that's
co-amplifying MYCN and MIB.
And you can see that there are two chromosomes here.
Those are chromosomes undergone a duplication where all of these
copies of MYCN, in this case, are clustered in a
single genomic region.
And we think this indicates a distinct mutational process.
Now, this is one example of a pattern that Amplicon Architect would call an
ecDNA. So we went further, investigated additional discordances
where we called the Typhonis and Amplicon
Architect called it ecDNA.
And every one of these we confirmed as being a homogenously
staining region. Now, you can see the scope here of Typhonis, the relatively
infrequent event
class that occurs on average in 3% of most cancers
and a higher rate in certain cancers.
But in fact, affects almost every known
oncogene, so cyclin D1, MYC, and
ERBB2.
And just to show that we're able to actually detect ecDNA with our
metaphase FISH, here's an example of
a
amplification that gGenome calls an ecDNA, and
indeed it is one.
So mapping these Typhonis events, we can see that they have an
extremely dramatic structure that involves both
amplification and rearrangement.
And we kind of threw every single technology in the book that we could at
sequencing these. Of course, our standard sequencing in TCGA is Illumina
short reads, which are less than 1kb.Long reads are generally
10 to 100 kb. Ultra long reads are a little bit longer than 100 kb,
and then optical mapping's not really sequencing, but it's somewhere in this 100
kb to one megabase
range. They were all really, even though we could get very detailed, kind
of plausible reconstructions of these complex loci, in
this case co-amplifying MIB and MYCN, we couldn't
prove
sorry about that, with even the longest of these technologies,
that this dramatic amplification was chromosomally
integrated. The way we could prove it is actually with a relatively old
technology, I wouldn't call it ancient just yet, called Hi-C,
which actually fortunately works on paraffin.
And here, Hi-C, it's used to study chromatin folding,
but also has become a workhorse in species genome assembly
projects. It captures 3D contacts, the frequency
of 3D contacts in genomes, and most of the contacts in
a Hi-C experiment come from the same chromosome.
They're cis contacts. And these can stretch for many, many
megabases, even hundreds of megabases out.
And this kind of signal is almost like an infinite long read, and it gives
us a very clean sort of landing pad for this
incredibly complex amplification on, in this
case, chromosome one.
So why am I harping so much on HSRs? Well, I think HSRs are actually
really interesting because they're good news.
I know we're trying to find targets for ecDNA, but
one feature of HSRs that might make it a sort of priority to
be able to detect them accurately is, for example, HER2 is a
target of
obviously a very famous drug called Herceptin, but also more recently an
antibody drug conjugate called T-DXd.
If a cancer cell amplifies HER2 on an ecDNA, it's more likely
to develop resistance to
either of those drugs. But if we can detect the subset of HER2
amplifications that are chromosomally integrated, well, then maybe those
tumors would have a harder time evading that therapy.
And here we find that a really substantial subset
of HER2 amplifications, we predict to be HSRs, either by
BFB cycles or tifonis, and that's both in breast and other cancers.
The other thing that's interesting with tifonis is that they're actually very
frequent in acral melanomas, not in cutaneous sun-exposed
melanomas.
And when we
correlate the incidence of these tifonis HSR
events across TCGA and correlate it with gene expression, we
find that they're associated with an order of magnitude higher number of
expressed protein coding fusions.
And we think that's really interesting because
that could make these tifonis a
source of neoantigens in otherwise
TMB-low tumors like acral melanomas.
And so we've been exploring this concept, and we actually have some preliminary
results showing an improved response to checkpoint
inhibition, even after correcting for TMB and other known
covariates of both SNVs and
structural variants,
rearrangement junctions that were amplified in an HSR.
And here's an example of a tifonis in a low TMB
tumor with a durable ICB response. This is an acral melanoma.
So one observation from
cataloging our dictionary of these complex and simple
structural events,
chromosomal events across thousands of tumors, is that they tend to
co-occur. So it's not just that some tumors have BFB
and don't have other event classes.
They occur and they co-occur. For example, these RIGMA that I
told you before often co-occur with BFB cycles and often
in GI-related tumors, even in Barrett's esophagus,
and that combination is associated with a much poorer prognosis.
So we wanted to see if we could actually combine these events into
true structural SIN signatures. Now, I think I
told you, and also you heard in the previous talk,
there's these copy number signatures which ignore genomic rearrangements.
There are these rearrangement signatures that ignore copy numbers.
So we thought, could we combine these approaches into a single
integrated structural SIN signature?
And so here we had to come up with a sort of feature,
a vector that we could put into our
NMF or LDA
inference process, and this included that
dictionary of annotated event counts and then additional copy
number and rearrangement features.
And this includes also that graph-based feature of the copy number that we
infer on junctions themselves.
Oh, yeah. This was us looking for names.
Maybe
not the best use of
LLMs and probably not the best venue, right?
The ACR doesn't like this kind of stuff. Okay, sorry.
So how many of these signatures do we have?
We've settled on about 30 across these tumors,
but that's still a work in progress.
And you can see each signature is associated with a combination of
this kind of word cloud of complex events and then a footprint of
these different rearrangement patterns.
Now, what's quite striking is that when we cross these signatures, when we
analyzed cancer cell models and annotated them for these
structural SIN signatures, and in
models in DepMap and correlated them with susceptibility to
CRISPR knockout or RNAi or therapeutic
susceptibility, we found
a large number of correlations between the burden of these structural SIN
signatures and
specific... vulnerabilities to individual
therapies. In fact, I'm listing a few here, but we don't have time to go into them.
But we found targets,
synthetic lethalities that were present, which both
were where we found the same target for the
susceptibility of the same drug and
CRISPR or RNAi target across many of these structural
sin signatures. When we did the same analysis with the cosmic copy
number signatures, we found way fewer such associations.
So in summary, these balanced genome graphs, I think, provide an
important starting point for studying structural SIN, which is in this kind of
right-hand side of what we consider genomic instability
related to structural chromosomal alterations.
We think there's a much higher prevalence of HSR amplifications than has
been sort of
represented in the literature, including through novel mechanisms like
Typhonis. We estimate about 30 dimensions of structural
SIN across
thousands of cancers, and some of these may provide insight
into targetable synthetic
lethalities detectable only with whole-genome sequencing.
And just want to put a quick plug for clinical whole-genome molecular
oncology. I'm a pathologist, and at NYU, we're
implementing
rapid whole-genome oncology, whole-genome
sequencing, and interpretation from FFP-derived DNA.
We have our FDA-targeted panel, and we're now
routinely doing whole-genome sequencing, and it's yielding a lot of
really exciting and interesting vignettes.
I want to thank the folks in my lab, and also the funding support from
especially Pershing Square and Mark Foundation, and of course, the
NCI for supporting a lot of our work.
Sorry to go over time. I'll take any questions. Thanks.
Anton.
I don't think we have time for so many questions, so maybe we take kind of
two or three and because we want to be on time.
Anton.
Beautiful talk, Martin, as always.
I was wondering about the validation of the HSR findings and the prevalence of
HSRs. I don't know if you're aware, but in most cell lines that you
also depicted here,
a lot of those HSRs might be a result of ecDNA reintegration.
So the structure between the ecDNA and HSR might be the same and which is maybe
why some of the algorithms also cannot distinguish the two.
And so have you tried to do this in cell lines in which ecDNAs
are known to be present and isogenic pairs in which those are reintegrated to see
whether your algorithms can distinguish between those two?
Because that would be really relevant.
And also,
a follow-up question, have you tried to do the same validation in patient samples?
Because we know that in patient samples, this kind of reintegration is a little
less frequent than in cell lines, so. Right.
So,
quite a few questions
to discuss there. I think the most
important concept here is obviously, when we see an
HSR, is that important?
Mechanistically, we can think about how did that HSR
happen. And if we're thinking about mechanisms and working backwards from
patterns to mechanisms, that's obviously an important thing to consider.
And did that HSR evolve through some sort of transient
ecDNA, and whether that's a circular ecDNA or maybe a transient
linear ecDNA. Now,
obviously,
ecDNA, we think
do undergo reintegration. I think what's a little bit harder
to understand is how they would reintegrate
all into a single
location, right? And I think,
part of that is sort of understanding exactly what are the conditions
when that happens. But we think that there's maybe a distinct
mechanism for particularly these Typhonis.
Now, whether that can be characterized as an ecDNA mechanism,
I don't know. But
I think
these kind of
questions are a little bit distinct from addressing what's biologically
important maybe for therapy, which is, what is the current state
of this tumor genome? And I think that's what we've been
sort of focused on here. But,
yeah, the challenge is obviously for human tissues is it's much harder to get a
metaphase
spread, so we haven't done that yet.
We've done it on some cancer models, like organoid models.
Isogenic models, I think it's tricky, right?
Because a lot of those will be... If we're talking about
engineered isogenic models, I don't know if we've got
great examples of that, but how representative are they
of
real human tumors? We'd have to see.
But I think these are all interesting things to pursue.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you for great talk. I have a quick question.
So in your fishing imagery of the HSR, it seems like
that some HSR is initially in only one chromosome, and then the
other one looks like scattered in the different chromosome.
So in Typhonis, do you think there's
two different mechanism that making different appearance in HSR?
I'm sorry, can you repeat the question?
Yeah. So some HSR is initially only one single chromosome in
your images, and then the other one is scattered in the multiple chromosomes.
So do you think there's a different mechanism for that?
The HSRs that integrate into multiple
chromosomes versus those that integrate... Right.
So I think this gets back to the question about
ecDNA reintegration. I
think-If ecDNA are existing in a
circular state, there's obviously examples of where they reintegrate,
and they probably will reintegrate in multiple locations.
Like for example, Colo 320 has
examples of... So there are examples of that,
I think.
If we're thinking about a
single reintegration event, I think the biology there,
I think
still has yet to be worked out. Now, how can we distinguish between those
different reintegration states?
I think some of that can be apparent on short reads.
I do think that's where longer reads can help, but my sense is
no long reads are long enough, and I think Hi-C probably
provides the unique insight to get that level of resolution.
And that level of reconstruction, cancer genome assembly,
is something that may eventually be important for guiding
therapy, I think.
Maybe we should take this offline.
I mean, Martin will be here after the talk and because we want to
be back on track.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you.
Okay.
So I will talk now about our effort for systematic
analysis of more than 8,000 TCGA whole genome sequencing.
And this is on behalf of a joint collaboration between Broad and InnoCrac.
Here are my disclosures, and relevant here are research funds from InnoCrac and
cloud credits from Google.
So just to remind you what said in the introduction, there
are limitations for PECAW with low sequencing coverage,
missing mutations due to PCR amplification, PCR plus,
so missing parts of the genome, lack of power to detect
drivers, particularly those that are in particular tumor types because those
tumor types had smaller cohorts, and a lack of
this accompanying other data like RNA-seq or
microRNAs, et cetera.
In the PCR-free whole genomes in TCGA, we
have deeper coverage, 80x and 30x.
It's PCR-free, so we don't have this kind of loss of coverage.
We have more than 8,500
tumor normal pairs, which is much larger than what we
had in PECAW, and we have this rich curated data set.
And here, you could see the differences in, for example, if you look at GBM,
it's much larger. You look at bladder cancer,
you see the new data is much larger than what we had in PECAW, and many other ones
are also much larger. So in order to analyze these huge amounts of data,
we created this analysis team together with
Broad and InnoCrac, and
co-led with Esther Reiber here and Youngsuk and Jihee,
and
other PIs like Matthew Meyerson and CZ and Ramin that are here,
and many other people in our labs, and
to analyze this data. So first, we want to
process the data and call variants.
So we actually had two different pipelines, one at Broad and one at
InnoCrac, to process this data. And we picked a couple of
cohorts to optimize our pipelines and to make
sure that they could scale up to run on this huge amount of data.
And it took us a few months to do that, and here's an example of,
after optimizing it at Broad, we could run
8,000 tumor normal pairs in less than four weeks on the cloud.
So we could scale it up.
And
all of this data together in December 2025, not long ago,
we called all these variants. We combined the data from the two different
pipelines, and we had almost 200 million single nucleotide
variations, 1.7 million double nucleotide
variations,
55 or 56 million indels, and 1.3 million structural
variations. And thank to the huge team of people involved
with processing all this data. And
we have also posters to go into these pipelines and
details, and I'll highlight this poster on the side of this slide so you could
write them down.
So one thing that we saw in the data, that there's a new sequencing artifact
that we've never encountered before, and these are
T to G mutate or A to C kind of
substitutions that had these are the quality of the
bases. And you could see the quality kind of decreases and kind of evaporates,
and we call that a vapor trail. And
this is new because these were sequenced on Nova 6,000,
and this is a new type of sequencing artifact that if we
don't fix, we'll find many mutations typically in the same sites, and
we think they are these somatic mutations.
So in order to do that, we developed a tool we call
Vapor Trail Filter that, based on this pattern
of base qualities and the sequence context, could filter
those. And you could see these are all the tumors, the number of SNVs that we
found, and the red ones are the ones that we filtered.
Some tumor types had a lot more than others, like GBM and KIRC,
and others had less, but we filtered all of these mutations
out
from the data. So we want first to make sure
that we're seeing something that makes sense, kind of.
So we look at all the-- this is 85 or
8,500 tumors, roughly, or more than 8,000 different tumor
types. And you see the different substitutions, and as we expect,
the top ones, the highest median here is with skin
cancer, melanoma, and the two lung cancers due to
cigarette smoking. You could see also the C to T mutations in the skin
cancer and the C to A substitutions in
the
lung cancers.Then we looked at the double nucleotide variations.
We again see the even stronger. Look at this big gap between
these and the other ones, and this is the skin cancer with the CC
to TT, and double
nucleotide variations, and you have the CC to
AA in the smoking-related signatures.
In terms of indels, we see, again, a big distribution
with many cancers that have a much higher number of indels, and in fact,
these are indels in microsatellites, and these are actually these
microsatellite unstable tumors or
tumors with microsatellite instability.
Now, did we actually fix this problem of the
lack of coverage? So here you could see in the PCG and the TCGA
exomes, we have lack of coverage in the either
promoter or first exons of different
important genes. Here we see then, if you look at the mutations
in exome data, you see there are these holes in important genes
because we don't have mutations because they have high GC.
When we look at the TCGA PCR-free data, there's
no loss of coverage, and we actually find mutations with new
hotspots in these regions that were missed before.
So in general, we are fixing this problem of a lack of
coverage in different regions. So in general, when we compare the whole genomes to
the whole exomes, we see a big overlap between the
genomes and exomes in the coding regions.
But in general, we see more in whole genome only, in
particular in indels that we couldn't find when we had the whole
exome data.
And again, there are posters that give a lot more information about this.
Here's example of some key genes that you're all familiar with.
This is VHL in kidney cancers. We find many more
mutations in the whole genome data, both SNPs or
SNVs and indels. And you could see them here in the
whole genome only and
there's some in the overlap, but mainly in the whole genome only.
Here's another gene that you're all familiar with, ARID1A, across
cancer. And you could see that this region
was missing mutations before, and
we find a lot more mutation in the first exon of
ARID1A that we couldn't find before.
Again, indels and SNVs.
Now, the TERT promoter mutations is in PECAW.
We had a big hole in TERT promoters because of GC-rich regions, and
you see here in liver cancer that these are the missed ones, and the vast
majority of ones were missed in PECAW.
And when we look at the TCGA whole genomes in that project in TCGA in
liver cancer, we actually did a targeted sequencing
of these promoters, and we see now that we are actually finding
essentially all of them with a whole genome data.
We actually find a few new ones, and we lost a few, and we're looking into that
to see what's going on, but we are finding them in this new data.
So what are the top 30 mutated bases throughout the genome?
The top mutated base in TCGA is one of the TERT
promoter mutations. So it's interesting that the non-coding mutation is the
most mutated base in the genome. But
the next second one and the fourth one actually, we think,
are artifacts. You see them across all tumor types, but the one after that
is actually the BRAF V600E coding mutation.
And
what you could see here that among the top 30 most mutated
bases, 10 of them are in coding regions.
So that shows how the coding region is important because it's only
1% of the genome.
Other things that we see are APOBEC hotspots in these promoters of
this PLCHS1 and the ADRG6,
and one of these hotspots, which actually a coding mutation in
PIK3CA that is actually functional, it's caused by APOBEC.
And as I said earlier, these two are artifacts.
So how do we find drivers using all this data?
We applied three different
driver detection tools, MutSig2CV, DNDSCV, and
DIG. MutSig2CV and DIG are looking more at the
frequency of mutations, where DNDSCV looks at the ratio
between the non-silent to silent mutation. This is in coding regions.
DIG we also use for non-coding regions.
So in coding regions, we applied all three, and we combined those P
values with this Brown method that combines P values of
correlated statistics that are not independent.
So we could calculate the correlation and then combine them.
And then we calculate these P values and look at the QQ plots, and there
are three types of QQ plots. There are the good QQ plots, which
most of them are the genes are the passengers or
non-drivers are on the Y equal X line, and then some drivers are kind
of above. And then there are the bad QQ plots, which essentially you don't find
anything. Everything is on the line.
And then there are the ugly QQ plots, which are either inflated P value
or deflated, caused by essentially bad
statistical models that you need to kind of fix.
And so here's the example of colorectal cancer.
These are coding regions, and you see we find all these driver
genes. Many of them are known. These are the blue ones, are known in
colorectal cancer. The purple ones
are known in other cancer types, but not in colorectal
cancer. And there were ones that were not known in any
one of them before. This BMPR2
has a lot of these nonsense and frame shifts.
Some of those frame shifts were actually not detected by the whole exome sequencing
data. And if we look at this,
this is a tumor suppressor gene, and we look at it when it's
truncated, non-silent or other non-silent, you see that it's lower
expression compared to the others, suggesting that it
loses function.So overall, we find
many drivers. The most commonly found
drivers that we knew about are P53, PTEN, BRCA, et cetera,
that are known in their cohort. But we also find drivers that were
known in other cohorts but in other cancer types.
Again, these are the like CREBBP, B2M, et cetera.
In the non-coding space, we're also finding new drivers.
Some are the known ones like TERT and NP53, and
we're finding new ones that we're diving into right now where it's still all fresh,
only we had the data freeze a few weeks ago.
And you could learn more in this poster.
So P53 mutations in the promoter or the UTR,
the five-prime UTR, were reported in the PEACOG,
but we find more of them, and we find both in the five-prime UTR and
also in introns. We find these
indels and SNVs, but mostly indels.
And when we look at them in terms of the effect on expression, we see that
those mutations that are non-coding actually cause low expression generally
of P53, losing the function of P53.
The other thing we saw in PEACOG were this in highly expressed genes like
albumin in liver or
surfactant in lung cancer. We see this pattern
of a lot of indels that are in the coding and the non-coding regions of
those genes, and we validate that.
We see it also in TCGA, we see it in albumin and the surfactant, but
we also find it in new genes that we didn't see before.
We see P63 in
head and neck cancers, and we find this
pattern of indels both in coding and non-coding.
We find it in GATA3 and XBP1 and estrogen receptor
in breast cancer. And these ones
also affect expression, even the non-coding ones.
So now we look at structural variations.
We see a big distribution of structural variations.
The pattern is different here. The highest ones are ovarian and sarcoma
and UCS. They have a higher number of structural variations,
a lot of things that
Marcin would be happy to look at kind of in terms of the patterns.
And how do we find drivers of structural variations?
We have multiple tools. One tool that we recently developed, which is kind of like
the NDS for structural variations.
We look at
structural variations that we think will have no effect, like the silent mutations
or the synonymous, and structural variations that we think will have an effect,
mostly in deleterious effect. And we look at
their ratio and see which ones are enriched in functional effects, and we
call it SVelfi. And then there's the method that we developed in
Ramin's lab, looking at structural variations
that are kind of recurrently connecting different parts of the
genome. So we applied these tools. I will talk about SVelfi results.
This, again, you could learn more in this poster here.
So here are the number of structural variation drivers that we found.
Some of them are known structural variation drivers, some are a known cancer
gene, and some are totally novel. Of course, some of them could be still artifacts
that we're looking into. Let's look at, for example, in prostate cancer that is
known to be affected
by known drivers of structural variations. So here are the top SVelfi hits.
The top hit is like TMPRSS2 and ERG, which we know.
There's PTEN and other ones, other new ones that
different labs are working on. But we wanted to look at this
one, this
SLC30A4 gene.
And this is an interesting gene. It has many translocations, both that are kind of
in the region, but also to other chromosomes. This is kind of what this depicts.
But many of them into known other cancer genes like ETV1
and MYC and others that are known in prostate cancer.
So when you look at ETV1, this kind of partner here,
it actually is connected to other known cancer genes that are known to be
highly expressed in normal prostate.
So TMPRSS2 and SLC45A3 and
FOXA1 are highly expressed in normal prostate.
Here, this is GTEx data. But also SLC30A4 is
highly expressed, suggesting that this is another mechanism to take a
kind of a regulatory region of highly expressed gene and move it
next to ETV1 to overexpress ETV1 in prostate cancer.
And when we look at the expression of ETV1, you see that
like the other genes that we know are causing high expression of ETV1,
also this new SLC30A4 also generates high expression
of ETV1.
So when we look at copy number,
what do we see in copy number? We see these patterns of gains and losses
that we see in cancer, and we saw roughly these big-picture patterns using
SNP array data. But now with whole-genome sequencing data, we could find
smaller gains and losses that we could not find with SNP
array data.
So here are the
estrogen receptor gene, and what we see are recurrent
amplifications of regulatory regions next to ESR1.
So not amplifying just ESR1, like known, but amplifying
regions that are next to ESR1, and we see the same thing
in EGFR. Amplifications of regulatory regions
next to EGFR in GBM, and that is something that we
believe is going to function. Again, you could look here more when you go to this
poster.
Then whole genome sequencing enables to study
chromosomes that we kind of neglected in the past, which are the X
and particularly Y chromosomes. And Esther's lab had a session
just before this one about kind of chromosome Y.
And the
most kind of exciting thing here is that the vast majority of
events in chromosome Y are loss of the entire chromosome Y, which could
have also potential driver effects.
And again, please go and look at these posters to learn more about
chromosome Y loss.Now we looked, as mentioned
here before, on HRD, and so the most known
signatures of HRD are these structural
variations and also signature 3, SBS3, and
indel signature 6 and structural variation signature 3.
So
Juno from the InnoCrust team and Yung Suk developed this
tool that estimates kind of
HRD and could applied it across cancer.
And clearly you could see it high in ovarian and breast
cancer, but you could see it also in other cancer types.
And, so this is HRD was found in 7% across all these
32 cancer types, with
3.3% are not in ovarian and breast cancer.
And the other
kind of explanation of this signature, including
somatic and germline, BRCA1 and 2 mutation, and promoter
methylation of RAD51C, et cetera.
But of course, there's also cases which we don't know why there are
HRD, and we cannot explain, and we should talk to
Jason and maybe he could explain some of them. Yes.
And again, look at this poster here.
Then we looked at germline mutation.
So about 10% of TCGA has known pathogenic
or likely pathogenic mutations, and this is, you could
see here, with the pathogenic and likely pathogenic different shades.
And using that, we could detect a novel
BRCA1 intronic splice variant that
you could see here. It's
a SNP in the germline, but it's LOH in
the cancer. And when you look at that tumor,
it has low expression compared to the ones that have no
HRD. So it suggests that this is actually HRD.
And look at the posters. There's more information there about actually showing the
splice kind of variants.
So,
just to finish here,
we have these many posters with different themes, and please take a photo of this
one if you want to go to those posters.
And we
collected all this data. We need to have more rounds of analysis, and we're
putting a manuscript together in the next few months.
And
once we publish, we make all this data available through the GDC
publication page, so everyone in the world could get
access. You do need to get dbGaP access to download this data because
they are non-coding mutations. That's the rules of the TCGA,
but then you could download this data.
And again, I want to thank this
collaboration with InnoCrust and the Broad team and different labs and
many members of those labs, which I can't name them all here, but many of them
are here in the crowd and showing posters, so please meet them.
And of course, the TCGA project and the NCI for
generating this and spending money to generate this kind of
high-quality data and ICGC to kind of lead the way of how to
analyze this whole genome data, and with the PECOB project
together with TCGA and Google Cloud for the
cloud credit and an internal Broad kind of
award. And of course, the patients and doctors that contribute samples and
data for research. And I'd be happy to take questions.
Yes.
Gadi, Tim Ley. Moshu.
Wonderful session, guys. Great job.
We take all this stuff for granted now, but I have a quick story to put things in
perspective. So 19 years ago, I was at a conference
explaining preliminary data on the first AML genome, the
first cancer genome to be sequenced.
And the pushback in that room was unbelievable because no one believed that
you could deconvolute and interpret the data because
there'd be so many mutations that would be completely uninterpretable.
And I wasn't prepared for this criticism, but someone came to my rescue,
Sherm Weissman, the great geneticist from Yale who sequenced SV40.
And he got up in the middle of the room and said, and I quote,
"If this goes forward, in 10 or 15 years, we'll be able to
sequence thousands of cancer genomes for the cost of a B-1
bomber.
What would you rather have, thousands of cancer genomes or another B-1
bomber?"
Silenced the room.
There is a challenge
for the field, I think, that no one's talked about today, which is,
it's one thing to do this sequencing, it's another to convince third-party payers
that this sequencing matters for the care of patients, which requires
a much more difficult exercise, which is doing prospective clinical
trials to prove that this information matters.
Because third-party payers ultimately determine how this information gets used.
It's just something for everybody to be thinking about.
Requires collaborations with the translational teams and clinical
investigators to get that work done, because we need to do
this all the time for everybody.
Thank you, Tim. Thank you for this comment.
I 100%
agree with this.
As you saw in the different talks today, there are clinical
implication of this. We're finding more mutations, more
signatures. With AI, we will need this data.
We're talking the need for 100,000 or a million,
or every patient will need to have this data.
The cost of sequencing is dropping and continues to drop.
I don't see any reason why this should not be part of standard
clinical care.
Together, married together with consent for using this data for
research, we could find a lot more of what's going on
in the genome and affect new drug development and new clinical
trials. So, I'm 100% with you and happy to collaborate
with you and the whole field here to make this happen.Yes,
more questions.
Hello. Thanks for your talk.
I was wondering whether you took into account tumor purity of the
samples while analyzing them and deriving
these mutational signatures?
Great question. Thank you.
We have actually developed a method, a new version
of a tool that we've developed many years ago called Absolute.
So we have a new version called Absolute2, which we're still working on
that, not published yet.
But we applied it here, and
we can get purity and ploidy for every one of those
samples. Still, we need some manual review, but a small fraction of the
cases.
And
we will
take that into account, of course.
So,
samples. The nice thing about TCGA, that they were selected to be
relatively higher purity tumor types of tumors.
I mean, pancreatic cancer has low purity, but in general, to get into
TCGA, you had to have a big piece of tumor resected out, because
back then we needed a lot of DNA in order to sequence.
But we now have all this purity and ploidy information, which we'll use in
all of the analysis. Yeah.
And that data will also be released when the paper is out. Yeah.
Stephen Chanock from the NCI.
Yes.
Adi, thank you. That was breathtaking.
That was really spectacular, and it was, I'm sorry to say, worth the wait.
I know the genome sat there for a long period of time, but it's beautiful to see
that. Now
that you've given us an incredible portrait across all these cancers,
I'm going to put you on the spot and say, what have you learned about-- Give me an
example or one or two of the cancers where doing this has really changed the way
in which we now understand or think about the primary
processes that are driving those particular cancers, okay?
Because you showed a lot of very interesting examples, and there's lots of
great detail there, but is our view of ovarian cancer
different now with whole genome or
gastric? I'm just curious.
So I would say that, first of all, we're finding-
Give me an example
... in particular tumor types of tumors, we find new
variants, even in coding regions that we couldn't find before.
UVM, for example, there we kind of doubled or something
the number of mutations in
BAP1. And so we are
finding new things in coding and non-coding, but you just heard other talks-
Yeah, absolutely
... about these patterns that
where are the ecDNA versus kind of
integrated into genome. How can we use this data?
So if you ask me one particular example
that we learned, I think we're learning things across all the
tumor types. We didn't kind of now have something we didn't know before
totally, but we are increasing our knowledge in each one.
I think the structural variation part was totally we were blind
to before, so understanding the structure of the genome
will open many more kind of understanding of how the
cancer evolved, what's the timing, when it started.
I mean, for example, in PECOG, we used the timing of
events. We saw that cancers started
decades before. The first initial events, the copy number changes,
occurred decades before the tumor was diagnosed.
That was a big finding. Cross-cancer, not just one cancer type.
So
I would say each one of these
concepts in cancer, we are changing based on this whole genome data.
Some we are changing a lot, some we are changing a little, but we're getting a
better view.
I'm not sure I can tell you one thing that we totally didn't know before.
We suspected things, but I think this ecDNA, I was very excited about
that, and the AI patterns, to get
new signatures on combination of these events to
new patterns.
There's also a poster from our group, from Greg here, that has
different kind of SV patterns.
So
I think that these are things that we learned that the implication
in the clinic is not yet known. But
once we have the data and associate with results and treatment,
then we'll know the effect. And of course, PARP inhibitor.
Who should get PARP inhibitor? Who should not get PARP inhibitor?
Things like that, we could do a better job than what we're doing today.
That's my thought.
Onto 100,000. Right?
What?
I said onto 100,000.
I say onto a million with a milestone at 100,000. Yes. Yeah.
You got to take steps.
Yes.
Factor of 10. That's where my physics background comes in play. Yes.
Other questions? If not, let's thank the speakers again, and thank you
for coming.